The next case is amens versus Wilson and company and it asks the question,
when can silence constitute acceptance of an offer?
Our El Amens was a wholesale grocer in Bella,
Mississippi over the course of six to eight months leading up to the events in
this case.
Uh,
he had placed a number of orders with tweety,
the agent of Wilson and company,
a meat packing business located near my hometown of Kansas City,
Kansas.
On each occasion he filled out an order provided by tweety who sent the order on
to his bosses in Kansas City who then shipped the requested good to amens within
a week with the order that forms the basis of this case.
This sequence of events did not take place as planned.
Tweety told Amiens that Wilson was offering shortening at seven and a half cents
per pound and tweety booked amens for 60,000 pounds of shortening.
This was a booking and as a really a way to say that,
uh,
for tweety to solicit offers rather than to make or receive an offer itself.
About two weeks later,
Ayman submitted an order for 942 cases of shortening that is about 43,916 pounds
of that stuff.
His order was an offer to purchase shortening in the given amount at the given
price.
Uh,
amens did not hear back from Wilson for 12 days at which point they told him
that they would not fill his order as the price of shortening had increased to 9
cents per pound.
Amens then sued Wilson and company for breach of contract alleging damages from
the company's failure to ship the request in shortening.
The trial court directed a verdict against Damon's concluding there was no
contract and so he was not entitled to damages.
We're looking at the decision from the Mississippi Supreme Court which looked at
the question of whether it was possible for Wilson's 12 day silence to
constitute acceptance of Amiens offer.
Note that even though they ruled for Amiens the case was remanded so that a jury
could decide whether Amiens allegations of fact were in fact true justice
Anderson turns to what is now section 69 of the restatement.
Second of contracts to determine when under what conditions silence can
constitute acceptance of an offer.
The section is quite restrictive because we generally do not want people to have
to speak in order to avoid being bound by contract.
Contracts are meant to reflect the conscious will of the parties involved,
not the accident.
Whole use of a default option taking on an obligation should normally require
conscious assent from each party even though an offer or is master of her offer
normally can add conditions as to how the offer can be accepted.
Remember an offer or might say and and as an example,
remember an offer might say that an offer can only be accepted by sky riding.
I accept,
but an offer or is not empowered to say you accept an offer unless you deviate
from your life path.
If you go,
if you go to work today,
I will have deemed you to have accepted my offer to sell your house for $1.
Or unless you say,
I love Kansas City,
you will be deemed to accept my offer to buy your car for 50 bucks.
Offer shouldn't have a right to make you speak in order to avoid contracting.
Okay.
Section 69 his first exception to this idea that silence is rejection is when
the offeree takes what the offer has offered,
knowing that the offer expects payment for it.
Even though the offer he is not required to speak her taking what was offered as
a conscious action and has similar social meaning,
it creates an implied in fact or implied in conduct contract.
Okay.
Section 69 second exception is for situations where the offer or has made it
clear that he will interpret the offeree silence or inaction as acceptance.
The subsection makes it seem like the offer could say something like,
if you don't say anything,
you have agreed to pay me $1,000 in exchange for this book and then the offeree
would be bound to pay $1,000 unless she said something.
But note the caveat.
The offeree must intend for her silence or an action to constitute acceptance
for this exception to to hold.
It's on the third exception that justice Anderson's opinion realize if the two
parties have a practice of behaving as if silence means acceptance,
then it may be reasonable to require the offer read to explicitly reject an
offer.
The justice found that a jury based on a man's evidence could reasonably
conclude that Amiens and Wilson had established a pattern where silence from
Wilson and company meant,
uh,
acceptance of Amos said this offer and,
and that acceptance that was taking on a promise to ship the requested items
within the week.
When Amiens did not hear from the seller for 12 days,
he could reasonably conclude that they had accepted his offer by silence and
that they had a contract.
Let's take a look at a couple of sections of the UCC that bear on this case.
Section one dash two oh one B three of the UCC defines agreement as a bargain of
the parties,
in fact,
as found in the language or implication from other circumstances including
course of dealing or usage of trade or course or performance.
This is a bit broader than the rule we saw on section 69 of the restatement
subsection one c,
uh,
of the restatement only explicitly discussed the prior course of dealings
between the two parties involved in the contracted issue.
The UCC expands this to cover usage of trade.
That is the general pattern of behavior,
uh,
in the industry at issue in the case.
If the parties know that silence is viewed as acceptance in their industry,
uh,
their industries trade usage,
then they may be bound by silence as acceptance.
UCC section two,
two oh six goes into more detail about nonverbal ways to accept an offer to buy.
Subsection one B says that prompt promise to ship or a prompt or current
shipment of the conforming goods constitutes acceptance.
Subsection two says that sometimes the beginning of requested performance
constitutes acceptance.
While none of these options is an explicit verbal acceptance of the offer,
they are all clear indications,
uh,
that are akin to implied in fact,
acceptances that the offeree has understood the offer and intends to go along
with it to accept it.
In this case,
uh,
of Amens versus Wilson and company Wilson's general practice of simply shipping
the goods in response to an order.
It looks very much like subsection one B's prompt or current shipment of
conforming goods.
So here's a quiz.
Gloria sends an order for a hundred widgets to Wilson's widget incorporated Wwi.
Males are back a,
a box of 100 widgets of the type she ordered,
but they're defective.
Can Gloria Sue Wwi for breach of contract?
Well,
the answer is yes.
Gloria can sue for breach of contract or order was an offer to buy widgets at
the listed price and wis prompt shipment indicated it's acceptance of her offer.
The parties therefore have a binding contract and so Gloria can get whatever
damages would ordinarily be available to,
uh,
for receiving the a defective products.
In our discussion of Amiens,
we've seen that the general rule is that parties must explicitly indicate their
acceptance of an offer order for a valid contract to arise.
However,
there are exceptions in situations where actions indicate acceptance as when
they shipped goods and response to an order,
or when the parties have established a pattern where silence indicates
acceptance.